- Actually don't sit down, I
wanna start with something.
Before we get going here, I
just need like a boxing tip.
Like I don't intend to
get into a lot of fights.
I don't get in a lot of
fights in my everyday life...
- Just in case.
- But just in case.
I know you've been in the
ring with Floyd Mayweather.
Arguably the greatest boxer of all time,
so where should I put my hands?
- So I gotta say, first,
you should be asking my
brother this question.
- Okay, okay.
- He's undefeated, and I am the opposite.
- Okay, but you did go eight
rounds with Floyd, I believe.
- Yeah, okay, okay, okay, okay,
so I'm gonna go ahead, take
my watch off for this one.
- No, you don't have
to take the watch off,
what are we doing here?
- Just put your hand like this.
- Which one?
- This one.
- All right.
- So I'm a little bit of
an unorthodox fighter,
and I fight with my hands down.
- I hear that, okay.
- And my jab is not your
typical jab from up here.
- Okay.
- I do like a snappy jab,
kinda like a backhand.
- Geez, geez, geez.
- It's like a backhand.
- Do you know about my
healthcare plan? Take it easy.
- No, no, it's all good,
now you gotta try though, obviously.
- So like a jab.
- Imagine like a backhand as a jab.
- Okay.
- A little more, a little more.
- Little more like this?
Oh, back of the hand.
- You know what? Let's do the panel.
- Okay, all right, all right,
good enough, good enough.
Okay, stick to writing columns,
is what you're saying, right?
- No, it's good, it's good.
I saw the tenacity in your eyes.
- All right, listen, if I
ever win a fight, you get 10%.
How's does that sound?
- Thank you, I appreciate that.
- So I wanna get to the boxing stuff,
but this is the "Wall
Street Journal", Logan.
So we probably should
start with some business.
- [Logan] Cool.
- You've been at this,
I don't know how old you feel,
but you've been at this
for a long time now.
I was looking at the record,
it's almost 10 years for you
in the business of social media.
- Yeah.
- You're only 27.
- But do you kind of feel
like you've been around
for a while in the business?
- I do, I do, I realized
when young creators
would start coming up to
me, that I'm now the vet.
And I had that moment with
the creators that inspired me.
And I look around at the landscape,
and I do have a pretty keen
understanding of social,
and that only comes with time.
So I do have to admit, yeah,
I'm knowledged in this space
because of my experience.
Like, I am a vet.
- Social media feels like
it should be measured
in dog years, I mean,
it feels like 10 years
should be 80 years, or
something like that.
- Well because it's always changing.
There's always a new platform,
and each platform has
a different language.
Just like code on a website,
HTML5, DOS, whatever it is,
it's a language, and social's the same.
I just happened to get good at speaking
the different languages,
native to each platform.
- Now, if you could go back and
visit Logan Paul circa 2012,
2013, we're talking about
still at Ohio University guy,
still starting out with Vine.
And you could give
yourself a couple of pieces
of advice for the next decade.
What would you say to that guy?
- I would've told him to go for it.
It's the one thing I didn't think I did
until I had a case study
that proved to be working.
When I dropped out of college,
I finished my first year with a 4.0,
it was a hard decision, because
I am a bit of an academic,
if you will, I love...
- What were you headed toward?
Like had none of this happened,
what career do you think
you would've pursued.
- I was going to be an
industrial and systems engineer.
- Okay, I don't even know what that is.
- They focus on efficiency in factories.
- Fantastic.
- Yeah. So, it was creative though.
You know, my goal, at that point in time,
was to invent a product that
would revolutionize the world.
And it turns out media allows me
to exercise that creative
part of my brain.
And it's a lot more fun.
- Yeah, I bet.
I mean, there was no blueprint for this.
There was no book you
could check out of Amazon,
there was no, "How to
be a social media star".
You know, it meant
successes, it meant mistakes.
You've had some high-profile mistakes too.
What did you learn along the way?
What do you think were
the most critical lessons?
- Yeah, you know, you mentioned blueprint.
I think anyone paving the way,
kind of making their own blueprint,
understands the difficulties
of what goes into it.
Because you know, there's
no path to follow,
you're paving the path, but
it also leads to sometimes
the most rewarding results.
I've had a career full of ups and down,
successes and failures,
but I take everything,
everything that I do,
and I apply it to the
next thing that I do.
The learnings, and understandings,
and I've gotten good at acknowledging
and accepting my truth,
and my reality, and then
using it to move forward.
And at this point, I've done a lot.
I joke with my friends
like, I know too much.
I know too much, and I feel like I can use
what I've learned to continue
creating that blueprint.
- The flip side of all of this,
the flip side of internet fame,
or any kind of fame really,
is that there's gonna be a certain number
of people who are gonna love you,
and there's always gonna
be a certain amount number
of people who dislike you.
Maybe even hate you, and
that's the way it works.
And anger's a very potent
thing on the internet.
- Sure, sure.
- Does hate roll off of you at this point,
or does it stick to you
and bother you sometimes?
- No, hate rolls off of me.
I have empathy for anyone
who has legitimate hatred
in their heart, it feels burdening to me.
And I simply don't have time
to focus negative energy anywhere.
And I've barreled through it all.
And I've learned that
truly if you don't give up,
you're gonna be a tough person to stop.
And social media's full of
haters, naysayers, doubters.
And to me it's all just
noise, because it really is,
it's a big world, and
everyone has an opinion.
But if you know who you are,
and you know what you're up to
and how you're gonna get there,
none of the other stuff matters.
- I mean, a word that gets
brought up all the time,
to the point that it's almost
meaningless, is authenticity.
And you once said like,
"This brand I've built,
you either love me or hate
me for exactly who I am.
There's no smoke, no mirrors."
You know, can you judge, when
you're looking at other people
who are coming up, when someone's
being genuinely authentic,
versus like sort of fake-authentic?
- Sure, sure, of course.
And not only just me,
I think the internet,
and people in general, are becoming more
and more aware of who is real.
And I truly do think authenticity will be
the key for creators,
celebrities, influencers,
in this next decade
because everything we see
has a level of superficiality
to it, or fickleness,
or you don't know if it's real or fake.
Even just like more macro,
like deep-fakes now,
like in the next 10 years or so,
you're not gonna know who's saying what,
because you're able to
recreate someone's face
and have them speak as if they're them.
- But they're probably
on the flip side of that,
there are probably people who argue like,
"Well, what gives me the
need for paying influencers,
when we can just create them?"
Do you think that'll always
be a fundamental need
for actual humans to do this stuff?
- I don't know, I don't
like to speak in absolutes.
So, I wouldn't say "always".
But my knee-jerk reaction would be yes.
I think like genuine,
authentic human connection,
the ability to navigate
and garner attention,
comes with a human, a
homosapien sapien, so yeah.
- You have a famous younger brother.
- He is famous.
- I don't know if you know that.
You mentioned him at the top,
I believe you live across
the street from each other?
- Yeah, yep.
- Are you competitive with each other,
or is this a real partnership?
- No, not anymore.
There was a time, this
is embarrassing to say,
but my most viewed YouTube video
is a diss track against my brother.
So yeah, there was a time where
we were definitely enemies.
And then we realized,
this is a weird journey.
Personally. I have one
brother, whom I love dearly,
and he's always gonna have
my back no matter what.
And in this interesting, eccentric,
difficult to navigate life
that we happen to end up in,
there's not another person I can turn to
that truly understands
what's happening and why.
We grew up in Ohio together in the woods.
Locked out of the house
for 13 hours a day,
because our dad made us play
outside and do manual labor.
And then all of a sudden, I'm
fighting Floyd Mayweather,
and Jake is one of the highest
paid athletes in the world.
How does that happen?
- It's surreal.
I mean, I don't know
the last time you guys
got in a car together, just
alone and drove somewhere,
but what is that conversation
like, just the two of you?
- They're the best
conversations I have in my life,
because we spend time
apart from each other.
And he has just as much passion for life,
and fervor, as I do.
And so we learn, we
collect, absorb knowledge,
learnings, meet people, and
then we exchange information,
and it's sort of like a master mind
when I'm just hanging out with my brother.
And he'll fool you online,
but I think, eventually
it'll be kind of understood,
Jake's a genius, the
kid is incredibly smart.
And so I get to see that side of him,
which is always fascinating.
- Now I wanna ask like, an old
man question about civility.
I'm gonna sound old for a second,
but you know, it seems
like the thing that sticks
the most nowadays on social
media, is confrontation, anger,
abrasiveness, hate, is
there room for love?
Is there room for being
somebody famous on the internet,
if you're about positivity
and using your forces for good?
I mean, it's clear there's been
a maturation in your process.
That you're a different guy
than you were five, 10
years ago, for sure.
- Yeah, it's a really great question.
So my answer would,
and I'm a bit of an
idealist, would be yes.
I hope so too.
Unfortunately I think
most of our species loves
the negativity, the drama,
just like that's kind of where we lean.
For what reason, I don't know.
And I've gotten the
opportunity to position
some really positive messaging
behind some of my content,
because of preconceived notions
about who I was. or who I am.
Which is interesting.
But yeah, you're absolutely right.
Spreading love, spreading
positivity, like in general,
like no one wants to see that shit.
It's unfortunate and it's true,
and that's why the
people who are good at it
are good at it,
and are making the waves that they are.
Because when you can figure out
how to spread positive messaging,
and really get people to feel and care,
which is kind of the staple of what I do.
My only hope with my content,
is I just wanna make people
care, make people feel.
- There's been a lot of conversation,
on all social media platforms,
about the idea content moderation,
and like whether or not things
should be more verified,
or shut down if they get too crazy.
What's your take on whether or not
there should be somebody under the hood,
making sure that things remain
a little bit more civil?
- Online? I don't know.
I think it's important,
I also think free speech
is important obviously.
- Yeah, what do you think
of Musk's bid for Twitter?
- Oh, man.
I think it's great just
because I believe in Elon,
and I believe he'll do good
things for the platform.
The spread of disinformation
is incredibly dangerous,
incredibly dangerous, and
it needs to be moderated.
What that looks like, I don't
know, I'm not Elon Musk,
but I'm sure he'll put
some boundaries in play
to protect the sanctity of free speech.
But at the same time
not allow radical dangerous
ideas to spread, I'd hope.
- If he called you up and said,
"What would be your recommend
for something like Twitter?"
- I'd say, "Why are you calling me, Elon
I don't know, dude."
(both laughing)
- Okay, so we talked about
this a little bit at the top,
but you're also going to market
with products of your own,
Prime Hydration, which is...
- Prime Hydration.
- Oh, there you got it, right there.
Okay, this is with your
old boxing buddy, KSI.
- [Logan] Yeah, yeah.
- Now I think of sports drinks
as a pretty crowded marketplace,
but what's gonna make this one work,
what makes it stand out?
- What sports drinks do you think of
when you think of the crowded market?
- Well, I think of,
what's the one from the
University of Florida, Gatorade.
I think of the Body Armor,
Vitamin Water, Red Bull.
Is that a hydration? No,
that's not a hydration drink.
- So there's three, right?
And Vitamin Water, I wouldn't
even say is a sports drink.
It's more of a hydration,
which is what we are,
we're hydration and lifestyle.
And if you can break in, which we did,
the market actually isn't that crowded.
We actually just passed
Powerade in sales at Target,
we're the fastest-growing
hydration drink in America,
and we're focused on
hydration and lifestyle.
Our drinks have less than 25
calories, 2 grams of sugar,
10% coconut water, 850 mg.
- Can I pour it over a coach
when I win a Championship?
- Yeah, and they won't get sticky.
Like, trust me.
Your coach you spilled
Gatorade on is gonna be sticky,
not with Prime.
So this product started out of a belief
that there was a hole in the market
that hadn't been filled yet.
And I mean, based on the numbers,
it turns out we were right.
And it has an incredible story behind it,
you mentioned it.
I fought my first boxing match ever,
was with a fellow YouTuber
by the name of KSI,
he's UK's biggest internet star,
and arguably UK's biggest star.
It was a tie.
We had a rematch, sold out
the Staple Center in LA,
and he beat me.
I lost by one point.
I'll never forgive Jack Reese
for taking away those two points,
but it's fine, because it
allowed us to come together then,
afterwards set aside our differences.
And we had about two years of realizing
that, me and KSI we were a lot more alike
than we were different.
And I don't think there's a better arc
than two people who
literally hated each other,
beat the snot out of each other,
and then came together to
start a global beverage brand.
That's cool to me, and it feels like
there's an inherent sense
of hope in-building.
That's what I'm saying, I don't have room
in my heart for hatred.
Like at one point, JJ and I were convinced
that we hated each other.
We were able to set it aside,
and build something really
meaningful and important.
And I think it's gonna be like a mainstay
in hydration and in beverage.
- You must get pitched
things all the time.
What's the worst idea you've
ever been pitched as a product?
- Oh my God.
You know, it's tough, I'm
not super nice with pitches.
Like it's tough because, dude,
I hear them all the time.
"Let me pitch you my NFT."
I go, "Stop, I don't care, I'm sorry.
Please, I don't want to
hear about your donkey NFTs.
Leave me alone."
- But you are getting into
this business, I mean,
you are into this thing
that's recently launched,
called 99 Originals which people
on your team call you, Magnum Opus.
And this is not just about you,
it's building what I learned
is this decentralized
autonomous organization, or DAO.
Sort of this online community,
but these are wild times for
collectibles, NFTs right now.
You've probably seen the
market and I don't know...
- Oh, I've seen the market.
- I don't know if you
look at your portfolio,
but it's wild out there,
but I imagine you are
more optimistic than that.
- I am optimistic, so I'm optimistic
in my project, Originals.
I launched at absolutely the worst time
any human could launch an NFT project,
but I believed in the project
enough, because again,
the story behind it, the significance.
And I think the depth
and what it represents,
in crypto, blockchain,
art, technology, DAOs,
Decentralized Autonomous Organizations,
which you meant or mentioned.
I just really believe in my product.
As I do with all my products.
Otherwise, why am I touching it?
I'm not gonna waste my time on something
that I don't believe in.
And so, yeah, Originals was
this Polaroid NFT project.
I traveled the world for 99
days, I took 4,120 Polaroids.
I traveled 85,000 miles,
and I selected 99 finals
to mint and turn into
NFTs, sell them one by one,
over a period of 99 days,
the buyer of the NFT gets the
physical one of one Polaroid.
- You get the tactile Polaroid, right?
- Exactly, and then what
we're doing is building
this decentralized
autonomous organization.
So the holders of the Polaroid
get to join this group
that have access to a community treasury
that they can collectively
decide what to do with.
I think DAOs of the future.
I think the groups of people,
without one particular
leader, and an access to funds
that people have a collective
decision-making ability,
to do creative things with, is the future,
it makes sense to me.
- And by this, you mean,
it's not just going
into Logan Paul Inc, it's going into this,
50% of it is going into a shared resource
among the people, who kind of
become shareholders of this.
- Essentially, it's
almost like a modern day,
like very simple version, of a fund.
Like right now we have
107 ETH in the treasury,
which right now is like
almost a quarter million.
And we're 10 days in.
- And in theory, that could be invested
into other projects and build from there.
- Whatever the community wants to do.
We'll vote on it.
But yeah, man, fund
independent artists, or movies,
sponsor events, donate to philanthropy,
like honestly, anything.
- I wanna get to some questions,
but I just have couple quick
questions about fighting.
- [Logan] Sure.
- I paid for the Mayweather fight.
I was super ready to
hate it, feel ripped off.
And I was like, you know what?
This is really entertaining.
This is kind of what I wanted,
what I felt I paid for.
I feel like with boxing,
you managed to get into the one business
that was crazier than the
business you were already in.
But, it's clear that
you and Jake have found
this avenue here,
finding events that people
are interested in seeing,
did boxing feel like a business
that was ripe for disruption?
- Absolutely.
It's a cheat code. I swear
to God, it's a cheat code.
When you were a kid,
you were on the playground
and a fight breaks out.
Where does the attention go?
Everyone goes to the fight.
It's the same thing in real life.
Again, we're pretty easy
to understand species
and it's the same thing in real life.
If you have enough of a gerah,
and you are willing to get
in that ring or that octagon
and quite literally risk
your life for entertainment,
put the work behind it
and you got formula for success there.
- I mean, it's amazing to
see the boxing community.
We're like, "What the heck
are these guys doing?"
And now they're like,
"They want to come in.
They wanna bring their fighters
together and the manager."
- [Logan] It's absurd.
- It's all happened.
- Jake just put on the biggest
female fight in existence.
Amanda Serrano versus Katie Taylor.
Sold out Madison Square Garden.
Had these women paid
more than they ever had
in their entire life for any.
And, this is like, at first
it was a young YouTuber.
It was kind of like a gimmick
and now the kid is undefeated,
he's one of the biggest
promoters in boxing,
and it's revitalizing a sport
that deserves a lot of attention.
- Let's get to some questions
in the audience here.
I'm sure there are some we
have right in the front.
Yes sir.
- [Boy 1] Hey Logan.
- Howdy.
- [Boy 1] I have a two part question.
So first one is, I mean,
you did Pokemon cards then
the Prime, the 99 originals.
So obviously you're a great
influencer and creator,
but how do you come up
with these creative ideas
for entrepreneurial stuff
to really leverage your personal brand?
- That's a great question.
The honest answer is, I don't know.
I have this innate ability to dive
to the deepest parts of my brain.
And if there's something
in there that I like,
I'll take it, bring it back and refine it.
So I'm a creative at heart.
I think I was blessed with the
ability to let my brain run.
And I've gotten good at just refining
and having a keen understanding
of what people are gonna care about.
And mind you, dude, I'm not always right.
In fact, I'm still wrong often,
but I'm also still very young
and every time I'm wrong,
that's a takeaway,
that's a blessing for me.
- Is there something just a
little bit different than say,
like, if you were just going
on selling merchandise,
hats and shirts and whatever,
then selling investment properties,
which effectively was what NFT is.
So people can go in there
and they can make a killing,
or maybe they could lose money on it.
That's a different dynamic
than just selling plain merch
and how does that change your thinking?
- It's what I mentioned at the beginning.
It's a language and you have to speak it
according to the platform
that you're navigating on.
Merch currently now for influencers
it's kind of overdone.
And so do we still want to
put our energy into that?
I don't know.
I thought I could make a
significant NFT project
with Originals turns
out thus far I'm right.
And again, I believe in the product.
And I'll run into the ground if so.
- Let's go.
We got another question in the back there.
- [Boy 1] Could I finish
my second part question?
- Yes, sir. Oh, sorry.
We just wanna get one
question from each person
if you don't mind I'm sorry.
Thank you
- Sorry. I love you.
- Nice to meeting you, man.
Thanks for coming out.
My question is you're
definitely super influential
and a leader in the space
for YouTube and social media.
What would you recommend to someone
who's trying to break into this space?
Which feels so late into
the game at this point.
- Yeah, dude.
Great question. Because you're right.
It is so hard.
And it's so saturated.
I had the blessing of starting video
when I was eight years old,
before a YouTuber was even a thing.
So when influencers became popular,
I had been doing the thing
that they had been doing for years,
and I kind of found a way.
And I feel empathy for creators now
who are trying to break into the space.
I don't know if you all know,
but the majority of gen Z took a survey
and these kids just
want to be influencers.
They wanna be YouTubers.
And I'm like, no, please.
Please be careful.
- We need some doctors.
- Yeah. you have to.
Please, we need doctors.
Be a doctor.
You have to have something
special about you, is the answer.
I think it has to be innate.
I think like we mentioned earlier,
an authentic likability
and you're filling a hole
that no one's really doing just yet.
Every new creator I see that makes it,
I go, that makes sense.
Or musician, actor, it just, they fit.
And sometimes you gotta break your way in.
It'll take a decade of
work before you fit,
but you put in the work
and I don't see how you
can't make it happen.
- [Man 1] Appreciate it. Thank you.
- This time just blew right by
and we have time for one last question
and I'm gonna take it Logan,
because I'm gonna ask my stock question
at the end of interviews with Logan Paul,
which is you can look right
down the barrel of that camera.
Are you gonna be running for
president in eight years?
You put it out there.
The possibility you'll be
35 in about seven years
or eight years rather that
would put you at 2032.
Are you gonna run for
president Logan Paul?
- I Logan Paul, will be
running for president in 2032.
- We can book that?
- Yeah, sure.
(audience clapping)
John F. Kennedy made Bobby
his attorney general,
where's Jake gonna go in the cabinet.
Jake is the secretary of defense.
- Logan Paul, everybody.
Thank you very much.
(audience clapping)